it is undeniable the Facebook has become
a part of our everyday lives while
waiting in line at the DMV we can see
that our mom's friend from church thinks
she saw Jesus enter chill lupa while
you're on this while you're on the
toilet you can see the girl you went to
high school with who traded her stepdads
doctor coat on for wine coolers is so
proud of her new twins and that Stewie
Griffin neck tattoo that's fun now the
website the perfected hate scrolling is
getting its own town yeah that's the
right reaction for that zero reaction
Facebook is planning a community in the
Bay Area called Willow Campus which
sounds exactly like what you'd call a
creepy tech companies manufactured
village and a dystopian sci-fi movie
apartments are sure to go fast now that
everyone has moved out of my space ville
oh my god what are you looking forward
to most about living in Facebook's new
planned community Emily I've heard these
legends about human friends I want to
try yes
it's overrated it's so overrated Natacha
being able to ignore casual
acquaintances except to give them a
thumbs up if they have a baby or a pet
died
[Applause]
mr. suckers died Natasha Leggero likes
this motion well now when my racist
uncle writes something racist on my wall
I'll actually have to make him paint the
wall yeah